Harry called his father on his 75th
birthday they've been talks about
Christmas them seeing each other I
presume you think that none of that's on
the cards now well I didn't believe it
in the first place I thought why would
he suddenly be all cozy and nice and
want to come and why would Earth would
Megan speak to King Charles if she hates
the monarchy so much I think it was
either a ploy set up so they can be nice
and then whack them a week or so later
you know there are people who do that
bring someone flowers and then smash
them up and vindictive in the extreme I
can't see why they did that they must
have known when the book was coming out
so I thought it was a very cruel move